was going on when we were away Xbox next
rumors going on potential 2026 uh shout
out to
wccftech uh they think uh the Next
Generation Xbox will be powered by Zen 5
CPU due to launch in
2026 and um says that it may be released
early in the PlayStation 6 as Microsoft
wants to set the message for the next
generation of consoles and also red
gaming Tech revealed the timeline and
said it may have shifted since the uh
documents leaked by the FDC early in the
year and um yeah they said that as for
why Microsoft could be planning to
release this uh console uh before is
because um the company wants to set the
message for the next generation of
consoles like it was successfully done
in the 360 generation the hardware would
be less powerful than the competition
but it would only make it cheaper than
the PlayStation 6 and allow Microsoft to
release a more powerful Hardware
revision down the line so uh yeah this
is a big one lot of thoughts lot of uh
debate and reference to this so I want
to start with uh I start with the best
spot I start with the best spot right
quick because I'm curious how you feel
he's he's a he's a he's a power guy he's
a I feel he's a guy
like he likes the power of mid
generation refreshes and consoles and
things of that nature but uh what do you
think about this man um if this rumor is
true do you agree with the strategy not
whole Pat you know where you at with
this um personally like I don't have a
problem with it because I can see how
it's um done and then what a way to do
it you know what I mean obviously if the
PlayStation 5 Pro going to come out and
you know still some headlines and then
Xbox turns around and releases a new
console they can do this and they can do
this at any time they want because me
and adct has been arguing as we argued
about this over our planet Xbox episode
where I said it doesn't matter when they
drop they can drop two years early and
be fine because there's not I don't see
a situation where a game that is
playable uh for the next console that
won't be playable for the series X right
so it's like they're Xbox with their
consoles are more closer to the mobile
of how like every iPhone can come out
whatever and it's just like hard where
yeah I feel like it's going to be the
same thing it's just that they're going
to they'll be able to front on the power
and and have developers you know take
advantage of it and they'll be they
could the only real exclusive they could
really have are the ones that are
provided by third party that's eager
enough to take advantage of that you
know that Tech um that's only available
that's how they got ahead with the 360
like there was just games that were just
available for a whole year for the 360
from 2005 to 2006 even going into 2007
that just they didn't uh port to the PS3
or that got ported to the PS3 much later
and it gave them like a huge leap I
think they're going for that again it
would be less disruptive I don't think
um it will be like a tight close off
where it's like all right here's the
next gen and the series X and S dies off
because there's a lot of games we've
seen the last two years that ain't
coming out until 2026 so are those all
nextg only games or like like that's
where I say like they can technically
get away with doing it and it it won't
be as like a a crazy shift and it
honestly even though it would be a next
Generation console it would probably
feel more like what the series X did to
the Xbox One X you know how we got
series X and S and there was really no
exclusive it was just games that ran and
looked better with the upgrades but
there was no concrete like next
exclusive they were just all Xbox One
games right running at um with upgraded
uh resolutions and frame rates and I
think it would be the same thing pretty
much serve the purpose that the PS5 Pro
would serve just to a greater degree and
I'm just curious to see what changes
they make that the the backward
compatibility would how how will will
they somehow to use machine learning to
you know put raay tracing in games that
didn't have it before like like like
would they I'm just curious I think it's
a good idea for them to break away from
this timeline same yeah they have to do
that and um if they it the reason why it
makes me feel good that they're doing
this because you know everybody says you
know Xbox ain't making no more consoles
um is that they still care enough to try
to give it like some sort of effort
where like you know what we we want to
put a console out want to you know set
the tone like we did in the 360 days and
the 360 was successful by beating PS5 to
pun like I mean the Xbox OG Xbox had a
short lifespan four years and um and so
I'm not surprised I'm happy with it I'm
I I'll support it but I feel like what
they're doing they're doing something
where I don't think it will force anyone
to move on for the series X and the
series s sooner than they have to but
they have a more powerful option that's
far greater than a PS5 and a PS5 Pro but
you know just ahead a couple years ahead
just to give them that room to like kind
of dominate the market and and and allow
their platform to mature to mature I
feel you okay okay I surprised I didn't
know how you was going to feel about let
get guys man let's get the sauce real
quick so I I got a chance to listen to
you guys a reference to your thoughts on
this you know this is a big talking
point between me and ran we were going
at it for a minute but um yeah just in
general like what sh I should say going
at it we were discussing it we were I
was say yeah we Wen going at it we W
going at it we going at something else
but not this but so where you at man if
if the rumors are to be believed in 20
26 is it do do you agree is the right
approach or you kind of like you know
what no y'all need to stay St Pat for a
bit oh actually had got a couple of
people in the know who actually told me
before the wccf tech that this is
happening but they're saying 2026 2027
2027 is more likely again
I but believe it or not Tom
but I think it's a smart move um I think
it also really right now as an Xbox fan
I get I'm a bit annoyed watch my
language I'm a bit
annoyed the fact that um it feels like
as Microsoft had this blunder brush
approach of let's get invite everyone
like that's the only thing I don't like
about Phil I'm like n man the console
make it because that's the the nucleus
of of this business and this brand um so
you know one people are already saying
there's not going to be a nextbox and
this would be a massive serving of crow
for them two it the thing is the next
gen console will be a tremendous
marketing beat because Microsoft needs
that breathing space PlayStation
dominates the air Airwaves massively
with the masses with the mass public
right so look think about it Call of
Duty is a huge IP Microsoft is now
contractually bound not to uh leverage
the advantage on its current gen
consoles over the PS5 but now it has a
play Xbox next nobody a say that about a
newcast exactly they didn't say they
can't be held back by that so the next
Xbox could will have uh if they release
it way
better you know on paper and hopefully
in practice way better a generational
leap in what Call of Duty performs like
and people will buy that the MS will be
swayed by the definitive version of
codon con
doing all kinds of like bro it's crazy
how the M the market is changing I'm one
of my boys he's big in the drill drill
game called fumes the engineer he now
was he's a PlayStation guy and he's got
a 4090 PC playing with a PlayStation
controller he's and all his boys are
moved to PC because they want the
definitive edition of what just Cod war
zone they just want to play COD that's
all they're playing you release a a next
gen Xbox get the name right for God's
sake please name right oh man they're
they screw up their name so bad it's so
important it's so important get the name
right get it uh get the all the
marketing push and this is going to be a
cross gen console by the like I it will
be cross start that that is the the case
now with this gen we saw it for three
years man but both consoles it just kind
of straddled the cross gen things it's
going to be a cross gen console by byas
extension so is the ps6 if if it comes
out it's not a USB stick be careful
around say that too loud I'm trying to
be careful I'm trying to be careful but
you saw
see talk say the words ps6 KS on on your
head continue
pause guys crazy think everything is
lining up because a lot of big games
this strategy is very risky as well but
Microsoft can weather the storm but it's
risky because obviously the PlayStation
6 could have technology that is that
would Leap Frog potentially the P the
Xbox next but then Xbox by then can then
commit to another M genen console but
the the strategy is risky but it works
really well and aligns up with their
software launch that yes console needs
to be front loaded with Incredible first
party IPS and without that it's not
worth doing I think that's where Elder
Scrolls coming out on the next box that
would be mad I think Perfect Dark is
around about there blade like this is
like the 360 gen when we got project got
them racing perfect dark zero to a
lesser degree but still a marketing be
and you had all these incredible games
so this would be if Microsoft once if
Phil Spencer says never got a chance and
never with the Lost gen guys can I
interrupt you right quick I just want to
throw something that's going to sound
very crazy it's going to sound very
crazy 20 years later right well 2005
launch title exclusives for 360 Quake 4
perfect dark zero Call of Duty 2 yo
history repeat not history
repeat don't get me gassed up now kid
that's crazy that's glorious those are
glorious it would work man that strategy
would be incredible think about a front
loed thing you're getting it the game
pass in Japan as well you've got Mina
working overdrive trying to completely
disrupt the market all the chips fall in
the right place and someone earlier in
one of the super chats did say made made
a great point where they said look with
all these Studios and breath of Studios
now under Microsoft's Banner you will
start to see that technology becoming
useful more because Xbox Hardware is not
doing what is needs to supposed to tools
or whatnot that kind of stuff getting
ahead of the competition getting
developers climatized to your Hardware
software and your tools two years ahead
of the competition is a big big plus
that her Xbox in this generation when
the PlayStation 5 was using the same Dev
environment that it relied on the PS4
now play Xbox gets a head two two years
potentially that's or one year
potentially that's a big big amount of
time to really go hard on the marketing
and Microsoft needs to do that and not
do some third
party I got one question before I pass
it oh guys yeah what do we do with the
Dual skew approach though do we are we
dual skewing or we are we one skewing
what we
doing no do not do a dual skew this the
strategy does not make sense if you're
going to try and under and offer a
cheaper alternative that's the series X
or the series s and even cheaper you've
got cross gen why do you need to doal
deal deal sco the whole point about this
strategy yeah that's done that's done
that's R I think that's done as well I
don't think that's going to happen again
I don't think that's going to happen
again this second sko is going to be the
midgen console that comes out later no
that's not true oh you think so King
damn no no cuz I put the video out oh
cuz you cuz you put the video Xbox front
line go watch that go watch go go go
watch that um yeah now soon as he finish
I'll tell you what it is okay so that's
what I think I think do not do not even
think about releasing a weaker cons the
whole point a whole marketing Bluster
about is most powerful console this is
it this one and have all this software
you've got you want to play these games
you can play on the Xbox you can play on
Game Pass you can play on PC you can
play everywhere but you want the
definitive console version of this it's
going to be this and I think that that
strategy makes sense with machine
learning and all the bells and
whistles love give them all AI right yep
crazy
ai ai up the wo the wo the W AI is the
future man ad man there something we've
been talking about room is is cooking
Xbox in 2026 what we doing you you Fest
you where you at or you die shout out to
the 1,000 watching get them likes up you
know you wipe your feet you hit that
that Bell when you come in you put the
thumbs up don't play with me please yes
there you go hit that like button yeah
hey come on 433 like what's going on out
something's up some stinks I don't like
it it got to be it must be a lot of
PlayStation dudes up in here saying
trying to figure out what's happening
what what what are they going to tell us
that we got to do this year what do we
got to follow what do we got to run from
gotta run from leaks boy so adct man how
you feeling Shades at 360 hour or we gas
should we should we just chill out and
relax I actually think they're gonna
they're going to pull a a AIU
what's the wi oh
no can you let me finish can you let me
finish I want you to go is gone thank
you can you let me finish let's he
they're going to they ended the Wii U
early to start the next Generation had
shot on everyone else oh I I see I think
that's what they're doing here I think
this year and the majority of last
generation was about damage controlling
what the the state of the the brand was
at the beginning they're starting to get
all their ducks in a row and I feel like
the best way cuz we've always said it
you know every generation's a new fresh
start and we seen how just a year
benefited Xbox with the 360 so you know
and not to mention not only does that
give them an advantage in that
perspective where you know the the
PlayStation 5 Pro is coming out next
year Well rumored come out next year so
that's genuine and that's actually
happening do you do you think that
PlayStation jumps the gun and stopped
supporting the PlayStation 5 Pro like a
year year and a half into devel uh into
this into the market like because it
puts them in a situation where it's like
do we let Xbox run wild for a year or
two with a with the the next generation
of consoles or do we cut the PlayStation
5 Pro
early and meet them in the Market at the
same time and and part of me is on this
I think that they know
they have games as long as the games hit
they'll be fine and and part of me
thinks like look you know we starting to
get these games together we're starting
to get out all of our ducks in a row if
we jump the generation
soon and and and are able to get to the
market before the competition because
look look what happens like every time
these new consoles come out it's like
the fresh thing on the market imagine
being the only fresh thing on the market
have it to yourself CU at that point
switches two three years the the new
switches two probably years uh well
almost three three years new like and
then you know people say well you know I
think they're going to cut tithe quicker
sooner rather than later I do think
there's going to be a loss cross
generation Gams but I think they're
going to lean more towards that gener
that next Generation only on that
platform like I think there's a chance
Blade the the blade is only on the next
genes and you know you know me and
smooth disagree because smooth says well
some of these games have been announced
for Xbox like but we've seen in the past
where companies said oh we're dropping
last and to me if they do that and they
have the games and they come out let's
say perfect Dart outer Worlds
2 uh blade Elder Scroll six next gen
only I think it could really benefit
them I I really do like it it only works
if they have the games if the games are
going to be critically acclaimed people
are going to like them you know people
could sit there and say well addict you
know they're not going to restart a you
know another new generation but it's
just like that's what that's what the
Nintendo did and it worked for them like
obviously there's a mobile market aspect
to that but when they when they they
realized early on we ain't doing nothing
with this Wii U so we're we're going to
abide our time support it as much as we
can and we're going to make our efforts
Next Generation and I don't think that's
happening now but I do think that
Microsoft is is better off cutting the
chord sooner rather than later because
not only like I said it puts PlayStation
in a weird situation I don't think
PlayStation letting them do that I think
PlayStation Cuts support sooner rather
than later I personally feel like that
because if if XBox had a year on the 360
and was able to gain so much ground
imagine if they have to give them
two and I just I don't see PlayStation
do it that if anything if there was some
leaks going on and the moment
PlayStation finds that out they're like
we need we need our next gen out sooner
rather than later and I'm sorry King
it's the ps6 like I I just I don't say
sorry to me just say sorry to
yourself you because you're wrong but I
mean I'm just gonna sit here until
you're
right that that's that's my thing very
intrigued on how this is going to pan
out and you know the funny thing is like
I said on on go live but there's a PS
six
like at least at least you know me at
least you know me at least you know me
but it's not it's not yo it's it's just
not and and y'all are so used to
something that y'all will like to be
safe I don't care to be safe out gold
play and I want you to make sure that
the Mallet look like a Thor hammer when
you're doing it you know
say's head at the end of it don't worry
even if PlayStation
can't even if PlayStation isn't able to
come out in
2026 they can't they're definitely
coming out in 2027 like early 2027 I
don't see them huh 2028 28 they ain't
come out 27 I you guys really think
they're going to let Microsoft run two
years in a generation by themselves it's
not what they let them do is what they
able to do they can't why you saying
2028 in general King the ps6 don't exist
why you saying 2028 in general listen
I'm well I'm telling you this if they're
able to make any moves it's only in 2028
the y'all don't read y don't read y'all
don't read I sat there and read every
document I sat there with bleeding
eyeballs reading everything and said and
you know I just felt like that I belled
the mouse like I got them like I've got
them so when dudes is sitting there
talking this crap like M it's going to
be this I'm like y'all just didn't read
just read and and the fact of the matter
that y'all didn't read is my gain it's
okay it's okay okay you're ridiculous
but as you as it goes on to you right
now King I didn't get a chance to talk
to you about this um no front lines out
there we had this in-depth discussion in
reference to you know Xbox next 2026 do
they set it off early do you you with
this you with this kind of first the
first the first paperwork showed that
they was talking about 2028 right yes
right and um then the leaks came out and
then all of a sudden these dudes is like
yeah now we can go 202 well well Phil
did say Phil did say hey those old we
our plans Chang yeah yeah we changed we
changed because we found out a lot of
new stuff like when you find out the
dude that you you you you going ball for
ball line for line he ain't ready yet oh
he didn't get his Beats right yet oh
wait a second he he can't make it to
deide with us this oh let's go it's a go
it's a go when you find out that you
going up against bases like this is
Tower let's play Tower Defense right
right and you find out they don't got
something on they side that could stop
tanks no massive make tanks make a bunch
of tanks and send them like we got them
real real quick question King do you
think if what whatever Xbox's next
console is do you think they do what
they did for the Xbox One to the series
X SN X where it is a kind of like a UI
not really a UI overhaul it's pretty
much the same interface do you think
they keep that or you think they change
it up no no everything is gonna be all
brand new spanking because thei I think
it would be a mistake if they didn't
that's nice the the the AI is gonna is
going to show you exactly what it's
about um okay so first first tanks they
found out they they they can't defend
they can't defend against the tanks they
can't defend so what you do you send a
whole bunch of Tanks you just adct is
the master at this what when he played
um when we was playing that Halo of Wars
yes he's the master at it oh they don't
got nothing that can defend about Ariel
send mad Ariel over there and wipe him
out no you know what I used to do I used
to send an anti over there where I knew
I would have tanks and I would send
planes over there to W to get the people
that I want to kill with the tanks to
follow the the the planes to my tanks
and do you see that he learned he knows
strategy but he's not using the hair now
this is what I'm talking about right
this is the part I'm talking about this
is what they said that if you want
somebody to not know what your plans are
write it down and put it in the
book I read everything read all I and I
said oh
snap these dudes don't got money these
dudes have been fudging numbers these
dudes have been actually weak as hell
and I've been said in there for years
but y'all waited for another dude to say
it for
y I said it ain't no PlayStation 6 cuz
when they say the competition will Leap
Frog
us we don't have anything that can
compete y'all are not
enough these are words telling you we
can't do
this when the CEO was selling
stocks why would you sell now why would
you sell it later win his ball valuable
no you going to sell now when you know
that it's worth the most now tell me how
we talking about Xbox and he's hijacked
there's no
place no no listen let's get to it let's
get to it let's get to it let's get to
it I'm telling you why they coming out
in 2026 I'm telling you why they gonna
punch him in the mouth they catch the
bully with his pants down hold up just
sock him right in the mouth drop him
right there saying they just Johnny
caged him just just catch him in the
locker room while he pulling his pants
up B just drop him cuz he ain't know
what you was there he didn't know you
was going to show
up now the two skew thing mhm it's going
to be one console one official console
gonna come out okay but they will have a
little man and little man is going to
change y'all saw that whole diagram that
they put up with the controller yes
those those modulated controllers M it's
going to be Tech inside that joint to
cloudstream immedi imately CL didn't
they confirm they canceled that whole
program though they didn't it was called
Keystone or something like that they
said they got rid of it they cancelled
the Keystone project The Joint that was
on his dresser I mean on the Shelf in
the back yeah completely different same
TCH completely different see the problem
with the Keystone was you needed a
controller so you're going to sell it
and buy a
controller uh you understand who's going
to walk around with this big ass
controller in their pocket trying to get
it over h we're going to rework this
let's rework this this is why that thing
didn't come out let's rework
it if you put the tech into a
controller that automatically syncs up
to any television anywhere right any
tablet any phone whatever at any point
in time and you turn that into a
battlefield anywhere you are for $150
$200 and it only streams this is only a
streaming device this isn't something
that oh this this is the dedicated
Hardware with That's how little man get
wings we got little man got wings now
and little man is not holding back this
guy because he doesn't have Tech in it
that you have to skew for right I'm just
saying like a cloud only device all we
got to do is just manufacture this
little dude let this little dude go out
there and do the Infantry work and just
knock people out go go little man go do
what you were made to do and go beat
people up real console comes out now
they got the games they got the games
y'all want I saw your Port begging
earlier I saw your Port begging earlier
your Port begging so hard yall got cold
out there making videos talking about yo
this stuff might happen and this stuff
might happen y'all are so hopeful that
y'all can get and it's not even for
y'all it's not it's for the dudes that
lay down easy it's for it's for Nintendo
okay so I can tell y now that's for
Nintendo you other Port bers y'all not
going to get there you gota wait but
this console is going to be AI I
run and it's going to Leap Frog them
just like they said it would it's going
to leave him in the dust cuz they going
to put out that Pro next year or or this
year I think it's this year that that
Pro supposed to go whatever Year please
put out the pro soon as you put out the
pro that's when your feet is stuck in
the ground that's when you're going to
beat the brakes off you this is where
youall bend over to tie your shoelaces
and we going to kick you in the mouth
and that's when the new Xbox is going to
come out now the name is key I'm not
going to lie yeah g is all not the name
better be the name is key don't come out
here don't mess that up just just don't
mess that up all right I don't think
it's going to be a serious console don't
mess that up just
just I don't know man I don't know I
just please don't mess let ask you this
though cause you you're of the mindset
you're from the era of we drop your
album on the same day as their album now
no no no no no wait talk about you
always been drop drop my game or the
same day as their game you've always
been on that type of time I'm also of
the the type of time to catch a dude
while he
lacking I'm I'm the dude that catch you
coming out there your baby mama house
what's up what's
up remember what you
said I'm that dude I'm that dude that
catch you when you thought it was nice
you
understand okay okay I got you now I got
you so just when y'all thought it was
safe to come
outside I'm that guy and I I want to C I
want them to catch them at their weakest
they weakest is when they trying to get
that Pro out when they got that Pro out
and your legs are stuck in the ground
and you trying to get your games over
there you trying we just trying to worry
about a generation that y'all quote
unquote said y'all W so I want y'all at
your weakest well y'all can't make the
pivot y already manufacturing this you
can't manufacture nothing else so they
locked in yo feet is stuck to the ground
s you got him now you just come behind
him and B
up put him down and put him down and you
can't be making that
sound you be making that sound that's
the new Xbox sound I don't like that yo
my my real rights know what happens yeah
I want I want I want them to get out
that car in that dark alley and just be
like it'll be really messed up if
somebody
ah right now so it's going happen
they're going to catch him lacking
because the huus on these dudes is
ridiculous I don't even know why they
would make a pro but this is what
they're going to do and this is what
Microsoft is going to do and they know
it it's predictive they probably got a
AI predicting everything that they going
to do over there and and and
strategizing against it but that little
man is going to show up but it's not
going to be what everybody thinks it's
just going to be a streaming device that
can go anywhere latch onto anything at
any time to get that pockets that's it
all right y got most of the points I was
going to say um look at the beginning I
was mixed only because there's a part me
it's like man y got the games now y got
the studos now like do you need to
necessarily you know jump out the window
so to speak but there's a part of me
that I was like you know what we got to
be real like 360 was their most
successful generation you know what was
some of the the differentiators the
differentiators was yeah they were about
a year or two to market right when we
had Peter on and Peter talked about that
you know establishing that and being the
first to 10 million whatever the number
was at the time and um you know the
thing that really is compelling about it
is that we have to be honest with the
series consoles one of the major flaws
we all had saw that series X that had
Halo infinite on the back of the box
yeah and Halo infinite was not ready for
lunch that Jak was there right so we
remember how weak the lineup was and as
the problem with the series generation
is in my opinion they haven't been able
to capitalize and gain the ground they
were because I don't as as dominant as
Sony has been with the 3 to one I feel
there's been opportunities for for Xbox
to exploit and they've had like a good
year bad year Good Year bad year so they
haven't been able to string it together
right so to me you jump out let's say
2026 or G say 2027 right you jump out
and we do know based on launch Cadence
of Xbox game studios based on now we
know ABK right and
Bethesda you could have a insane killer
lineup of titles at this new hardware
launch and showcasing what you're about
to do so that does show strength and
then like to your point King PS5 I mean
PS5 Pro is already out you then Lea frog
that right pretty quickly it it because
be honest a lot of the fear of the um
you know the Xbox fan who wants the mid
generation refx is like damn you're just
going to let them be out there with a
PS5 Pro just and we all know them
digital found joints going to come out
right and they going like oh this is how
GTA 6 looks over here you know saying
this is how it looks over there on your
platform and we know how damaging that
was for
Xbox could you imagine a Call of Duty
yes that they could only get streaming
on a joint because their Hardware is not
capable to run it yeah and and what I
like about it is dictating your own
terms right coming out you set the brain
because like Nintendo they move to their
own drum they're not waiting for
whatever move to your own dictate your
own pace and separate yourself because
let's be honest as much as people don't
want to admit it we have to admit
PlayStation is a global brand we have to
admit that so if you keep going head
tohe head and launching your stuff at
the same time with a global brand it's
not smart you got to be honest we we
have to be real about the situation now
if you put yourself out there establish
yourself out as this is the place to
play oh by the way oh here's the new
gears oh here by the way here's the new
perfect dog oh here by the way here's
blade here's Clockwork Revolution here's
oh by the way in a two-year window cuz
we have to admit that launch lineup of
the 360 the first year the two years are
insane like the whole conso generation
was insane but particularly the amount
of games that came out G Rec but it's
like bro it was just massive and now you
talk about playing these games or more
powerful Hardware that's super
attractive right and you establish Game
Pass as and I told people all the time I
don't care what nobody say that Call of
Duty is in Game Pass it's going to hit
different and Sony said it themselves I
even Sony said it you know what I'm
saying it's going to hit you got the
call now they can't legally they say
yeah we we ain't got no statistical
advant no no advantage over y'all except
with new hardware
though hey we can't we can hey this all
stuff more power we can't say nothing
about that right at this point so I
think that's cool my only fear I have
one fear about it one concern is that
provided the pivot did happen and there
is this change and they are now doing
this my only concern please the yields
y'all the yields please cuz we we went
through a red ring of death cuz y'all
you know moving a little fast you know
what I'm saying so so just please from a
hard that AI [__] messing up I just
whatever I I I hope Jason Ronald and the
teams have have really you know dialed
in as far as that aspect you know what
I'm saying because that's the only thing
that could really derail that if if
you're you know you're moving a little
too fast but look these guys are in
positions way smer than me they they
understand the business they understand
design and all that other kind of stuff
but um yeah and then the messaging the
messaging has to be airtight I have
confidence in Xbox Hardware messaging
though when it comes to man for
promoting hardware and controller oh
they going you gonna get the graphic the
you gonna get it all you gonna get so
they got to do that but they got to also
really promote the Game Pass element as
as well as that launch lineup and and
and the message to current series exit
as old it's just hey this is how you're
going to be able to play the games we're
not going to leave you behind and if it
will be the cloud will allow you to play
on the series as so uh a series Xbox
next only game so to speak that kind of
thing so look that's going to be the key
for them but yeah I think it it would be
a sound approach I'm actually coming
around to it a bit more so yeah I wasn't
down with it in the beginning yeah at
first I was a little cuz I was like do I
need to do it I was like would you fight
them then I thought about it I was like
then I saw the paperwork and I was like
get
him but I all like go good guys anything
else before we move on no I just I just
think that that that's the smart play it
it it works on many levels that you get
ahead of the competition you really do
also reinvigorate the brand and the
reassure the fan base and Phil Spencer
is aware of the fact that people like us
uh are a bit annoyed about the console
being
relegated you know to so you that
addresses that and and then and the
marketing push that's the big one Xbox
has everything there it has the games it
has everything going for it but people
still don't you know with the even with
Game Pass marketing well but once you do
this then you have the best chance Xbox
everything this is the problem with Xbox
and so got I got so annoyed in 2022 when
they dropped the ball that moment killed
the momentum from 2021 killed it yeah
exactly well they killed it right off
the bat cuz they had no exclusives at
the launch which is shocking so that
that it was it was really high that that
could have been a very disruptive gen
like way more than what game pass is now
they're riding on Game Pass but it would
have been really a whole different story
if this was if this was the case but now
with all these Studios and all these IPS
with the sheer number alone that
software lines up you get your marketing
beat and then you've got a lot of
inroads in in Japan and everything like
that whole facet of this this is the
chance for Microsoft to really take it
to Sony hopefully we don't get another
Co yeah yeah that part yeah that part
yeah or they do get another Co and the
freaking industry goes up high cuz you
remember they people sitting at home
they'll be buying the console yeah but
the thing was you know they they caught
Co bug and then Halo wasn't ready and a
lot of games wasn't ready but Sony had
they the old stuff and tuck it was like
Yay put it up to new resolution and put
it out the door think think think about
the potential right we know you talk
about Halo you you can have all these
front loaded you have Elder Scrolls you
have the new Cod you have a perfect dark
you proba have State of Decay probably
then as well stagger it out though don't
do don't do a Dreamcast oh they will you
know stagger it out or show show of
force but then you also have a future
road map what whatever's Doom whatever
was working on that you have Halo yes
remember Halo yeah remember that yeah
that the next year the following year
that's a good point we forgot about Halo
at that time we'll probably see
something related to uh gears too the
next ABS absolutely all those be one
pocket Xbox has the potential to to
dominate this industry it has everything
in its Arsenal everything the the bank
the the studios the I I don't want these
PlayStation dudes I don't want y'all to
get it twisted right now CU you dudes
right now think we talking about wait to
2026 no we're gonna beat your breaks off
every day up until 2026 and that's when
it going to really start to happen so I
don't want y oh no don't get it twisted
this ain't wait till 2026 this is boot
on the neck now
day we keep that boot on your neck hash
there won be no PlayStation 6 Kong will
die not going to stop bro oh I got you
thank you for keeping me in line I I
know where you was at okay cool going
keep these beating up okay I don't think
this is like Microsoft saying waight
till 2026 I think I personally feel like
they have if they at that time they'll
probably have the majority of their
Heavy Hitters I would say Fable is most
likely going to be across game be on
both and I think that they'll put thems
in a situation where it huh no I saying
don't forget about remember that
Clockwork re in Exile yeah that that'll
probably be time too and to me it's
going to be one of those situations
where they're like we got the gains we
got the
services we just need fresh new hardware
to really generate hype and it's like I
said like I personally don't feel like
PlayStation will let them run wild for
years I don't
I think I think PlayStation is going to
prematurely end this generation just
like Xbox
will they going
prematurely into the
situation it's not about affording or
not affording it's about PlayStation
already knows what they're doing is is
blown up in their face they they they
trying to you know have some sense of uh
and they know that what happened the 360
era so to me I don't think is there a
chance that happens again probably not
but in the back of PlayStation's mind
you can do a lot of damage in two one to
two
years and I don't think PlayStation can
afford to take the rks but but they got
they they locked into a PS5
Pro but that's what I'm saying they
they'll let that they'll let that sucker
run wild for like a year and a half then
we'll cut
it hold on hold on hold on let me get
the reut real quick okay all right so
this is why they're not GNA do what you
talking about um they just got to the
point where they making some bread off
of these consoles and they still selling
these things aren't G to stop selling so
why go to the part where we losing again
on Hardware just to go to beat somebody
that we feel that we could beat anyway
let them do what they're G to do we just
started making some money we seen from
all these leaks they don't feel like
they they feel like they're going to get
leap frogged they they don't feel that
way though right but they just started
making some money so why you going to
put out Hardway they going to put them
deeper into the hole let's build our
bank up so we can come at these dudes a
little bit harder and they do they want
to do and you know what's crazy let's
say that they let's say it does come out
in 2026 and Playstation 4 does wait till
like 2028 then then micro that's when
Microsoft can launch the slim the pro
potentially announce their Pro if
they're going to make one the the leaks
does say that regardless of whenever
PlayStation 6 the bad word here when
around King um whenever that does um
happen that they were going to launch a
pro in combed that regardless so okay I
am with you guys I don't think they're
gonna have uh I don't think they're
gonna have a uh any form of like a
version of the series s now the
streaming thing is a possibility off of
King but I I think they are done with
the two SKS console yeah I forgot to
mention that yeah I think I think I and
and not to mention if if you launch in
2026 and there there's there's no new
console around you at all and nowhere in
the foreseeable future then why would
you do it you don't need because you can
you're going to be the only person on
the market why you need to fight two see
the reason they made the series s and
the x is because they needed they needed
the fight on the the the the value and
the fight on the power but by then
they'll have power because they'll be
out two years after the pro and on top
of that there's no reason to fight value
cuz they're the only ones there I agree
no I 100%
going to say something for him before I
was agree with